(slow electronic music)
- Hey good morning you little bitch!
Hey let's roll running awaits!
Fuck!
(TV chatter)
- Fuck yeah dude!
Sex and the City marathon.
- Such a classic episode.
Charlotte's dog gets its
period at the dog show
and then Aleksandr
Petrovsky ices out Carrie.
- I know dude, some of SJP's best work.
- Dude what is it about her?
She's like the fuckin' master man.
- Morning!
- [Both Men] Morning.
- Are you eating my orange chicken?
- Uh, yeah I am Marty!
You left it at Anderson's refrigerator.
- It's fair game dude.
- Yeah, so no offense but like fuck you!
- (chuckles) Marty we're
gonna hike running,
you wanna come?
- Yeah Marty, you should come.
Drop some of that baby fat.
- Yeah Marty, you got
like a whole baby worth of
baby fat right now.
- Fuck you guys, what's this?
- Stop, stop, dude it's not funny, dude!
- That's super mean Marty.
Just come running with us.
You're not fat, alright?
- I'm busy!
- With what?
- Yeah, what do you even do Marty?
Other than ball us and
look fuckin' treacherous.
- I'm a graphic designer!
(men laughing)
- I thought you said you
were a divorcee looking for
a good time.
- That's no a job.
- She's so mad right now.
- What are you doing?
We're like conversing with you Marty.
- Voicemail.
- Dude, that's fucking rude
you chunky garbage skank.
- You're fat.
- Marty look, I said stop, so.
- Seriously Marty, you
should come with us.
You're looking haggard as fuck.
- Yeah, that's not what you
said last night when I was
sucking you little dick.
(Anderson laughs)
- That's fucking cold Marty.
- One, that's a good burn.
Two, she sucked your dick last night?
She sucked my dick last night.
- Uh, I tried to suck your
dick, you couldn't get it up.
- Alright, fuck you Marty, very funny.
Although it is sort of weird.
I've been having sort of
a hard time with that.
Like ever since my girlfriend
died, (laughs and cries).
I'm sorry dude.
- Wait, backtrack, when
did she not suck your dick
last night?
- Like right after we
got off from Pandawan,
you were taking your post panda shit.
- Oh, the best.
- Wait Marty, I can't
believe you attempted to suck
two dongers in a 15 minute time window.
I'm almost like not
even mad at you anymore.
- Yeah dude, that's impressive.
- I'm on the phone!
I can't believe I fuck these children.
- What children?
- That was my doctor, fuck!
It wasn't a razor bump.
It was herpes.
Sorry.
- It's all good, I've already got it.
- I also have it too.
(theme music)
What's up?
- What's up!
Dude I fucking spent that
whole episode just like
dreaming of Marty's gazongas.
(Zac laughs)
Like floating about me,
like some sort of celestial
fucking ballet dude (laughs).
- Dude for me, it's like I
can't stop thinking about
my fuckin' panda dump.
- Oh yeah dude, that's so nice.
Oh, dude!
Okay, so like, what's
your fuckin' favorite food
to just fuckin' lubricate you
passing of stool (chuckles)?
- Shit dude, that's a good question.
Let us know in the comments section.
We want to know your answers.
- Yeah dude, and fucking
while you're commenting,
like use your fuckin'
mouse to like subscribe,
and fuckin' hit links and
google further information.
- Fuck yeah dude, computers.
- Fuckin' computers dude.
(wind gurgling)